je m'y attendais pas parce que je savais
que
une collègue un groupe de collègues
cécile marais d'yves bellerose et
olivier auguste présenter un autre
reportage sur la problématique lors des
comme un reportage que j'avais crevé
exceptionnel et pour moi c'était le prix
aliker de cette année donc une grande
surprise d'autant que c'est pas moi il
n'y michel qui avons déposé ce reportage
mais stéphane petit père qui voit là
qu'il a déposée pour nous c'est une
problématique grave lourde et puis la
mise en image aussi parce que c'était
difficile à tourner le business du mythe
du le business du médicament haïti
c'est une problématique dangereuse qui
mène parfois à la mort donc ça touche
tout le monde de voir que des
médicaments périmés ou des faux
médicaments dangereux sont vendus
sous couvert de fausses pharmacies en
plus des officines qui n'ont pas de
pharmaciens mais monsieur tout le monde
vend des médicaments ou parfois même des
médicaments vendus dans la rue
donc je pense que c'est ce qui a dû
toucher le jury qui la réalisation qui
était compliqué car on a dû tourner dans
des quartiers on n'était pas les
bienvenues les vendeurs à la sauvette de
médicaments ne veulent pas être fumé on
a dû utiliser des caméras cachées et
aussi filmé dans un pick-up avec des
vitres complètement fumée donc ce
n'était pas évident à la fois à tourner
mais aussi pour obtenir des témoignages
de gens parce que il ya beaucoup
d'argent derrière ce business